listen if you hate it if you hate being
debt free you can always get back in
goor that's what you choose and that's
the life you want you can always do it
but there's something about living in
this mentality when you don't owe
someone anything nothing it's just a few
of those decisions painful hard
decisions sometimes when you're in the
midst of it but it's just saying hey
this this and this for a period of time
and that's the problem John I think is
that people they're comfortable where
they are and it kind of is working I
mean you know what I mean like this is a
great example I'm like yeah $28,000 car
loan $28,000 St I we could kind of just
truck along pay you know an extra
thousand a month you know and you're in
it for for three four years and it's oh
man I need new tires well you can just
Finance those just kind of like go along
and then you look up it's been five
years and you're like we've made I've
made no progress like and I dug my whole
deeper right yeah that's right that's
right so the habits you guys if you're
not happy with the situation you're in
financially that means the way you're
handling money the way you're viewing it
it has to change